as we saw their China's economy now
swings a very heavy stick indeed not
just in terms of the production of goods
but also when it comes to consumption
here to look at the current situation is
the director of the Hamburg Institute of
International Economics heading for both
heading welcome to made in Germany
thanks for being our guest is this just
a correction or has the bubble in China
really burst well it's hard to say
actually right now hopefully it's just
the correction of market expectations
but maybe it's it's a bubble that is
bursting because the government and the
in the past has fueled a kind of a
bubble but it remains to be seen whether
a bubble is really bursting you say the
government has fueled a bubble but now
Beijing is doing everything it can to
prevent panic are those measures working
I don't think so once a crisis is
triggered or expectations are worsening
then it's very difficult for the
government to intervene to stabilize
markets we have seen this many times
before in such a crisis and it remains
also in this case to be seen whether the
government can succeed in stabilizing
the Chinese economy what options does it
have well we can just provide more cheap
money buying bonds and and other shares
to to stabilize the stock exchange but
this cannot really solve the problem
that is behind the crisis because there
is a slowdown in the real economy and
the real Chinese economy and so market
expectations have to adjust to what we
can say in you growth path in China okay
you say market expectations have to
adjust but for the last 20 years or so
China has gone at least from an outside
perspective from strength to strength is
this optimism that's been generated
going to dissipate with the current
crisis I think so yes we have seen this
in many other countries that after a
long period of fundamental and and huge
growth economies
we'll are moving into a phase of lower
growth and this is exactly what will
happen in China so we we have to adjust
our expectations of let's say double
from double-digit growth to let's say
five or six percent and future years the
world bank said in its spring report
that the Chinese state had gone beyond
its role as a regulator and engaged in
active interference how much of this
bubble was just created by the
government it was mainly created by the
government you to achieve money monetary
easing and an undervalued currency the
renminbi is undervalued towards the Euro
of the US dollar and this has lat or
contribute at least two to a bubble that
could now be bursting and but now I
think Beijing is is being aware that the
Chinese economy is facing limitations of
growth and will be on the transition to
more sustainable growth in China is a
communist country but yet we're hearing
things like private investors borrowing
money to invest in the stock market and
make even more money that doesn't sound
very communist to me yeah it is it's a
mixture a very strange and special
mixture of capitalism and communism and
China has has taken this this model to
promote and to foster growth in China
and we will see where it pays off in the
future what would it mean for the rest
of the world if the bottom falls out of
the market in China well we see that the
global economy is in there's a special
moment of the of the global economy
there are many downward risks to the
global economy and so China is crucial
for growth of the global economy and if
China will be will be bursting the
bubble we're bursting in China this
could hit there the global economy quite
usually okay heading for a book thank
you very much for being our guest today
on made in Germany thank you